Ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week where my life has
felt normal that was when you found out
when you botched that spell where you wanted
everyone to forget the peter parker spider-man
we started getting some visitors
from every universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your
name again dr otto octavius
wait no seriously what's your actual name are
others out there we need to send them back
so scooby-doo this crap you know
all this is kind of your mess
i know a couple of magic words myself starting
with the word please please scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the
darkness to fight ghosts
what do you mean they all die
fighting spider-man it's their fate
i'm sorry kid yeah me too don't
there has to be another winch there isn't
there a danger to our universe you're
not gonna take this away from me
peter you're struggling damn everything you
want while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save everyone
what's happening they're starting to
come through and i can't stop them
Welcome back everyone happy spider-man week
marvel and sony dropped the new spider-man
no way home trailer with a whole bunch of
easter eggs and the full roster of sinister
six villains so we'll break it all down
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs here
so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get everything
we're doing a giveaway for imax tickets all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just leave your favorite easter
egg from this new trailer on the video
the big thing with this new trailer is everyone
was wondering how much more they would show us in
terms of the characters because there been all
the rumors about daredevil matt murdock leaks
toby maguire andrew garfield leaks from the past
week but here's the thing there's actually a scene
later in the trailer where the lizard seems
like he gets punched in the middle of the air
but there's nothing around him i think there's
another version of spider-man here like maybe
andrew garfield's amazing spider-man and they just
edited the trailer to be kind of misleading the
way that marvel does that sometimes but we did get
our confirmed five sinister six villains really
it's a sinister five because it's just alfred
molina's doctor octopus willem dafoe's green
goblin and thomas hayden church's sandman all from
the toby mcguire spider-man movie spider-man one
two and three then jamie foxx's electro and
rhys ethon's lizard from the andrew garfield
amazing spider-man movies with all them getting
slight redesigns like costume tunings but made
to look as close as possible to their original
versions of their characters from those movies
because even though green goblin's costume looks a
little bit different a little bit shinier it's the
same deal with dr octopus's costume his octopus
arms look the exact same although now confirmed
that he does get a giant iron man upgrade during
the events of the film but since this is just
going to be my quick reaction video we'll just go
through shot by shot talking about the really big
wtf moments in easter eggs so when he's all beaten
up bloody standing in the rain talking about the
one week of his life that he got to enjoy actually
being spider-man he's talking about the week that
overlaps with the end of spider-man far from
home in the beginning of spider-man no way home
but it sounds like they performed doctor strange's
spell and things go off the rails about a week
after that happened after she learned his identity
he also mentions the spider bite i don't know
if we're ever gonna see that they just announced
that spider-man freshman year tv show that they're
gonna do on disney plus for his character during
his freshman year at midtown high so maybe we'll
see the spider bite during that we get another
scene with spider-man versus a subway train which
just reminds you every single time of toby mcguire
in the doctor octopus fight during spider-man 2
because doctor octopus also a big character during
this and we have the other multiverse scene of
doctor strange with the many different trains just
warping around them a lot of the scenes during the
trailer are meant to be references to scenes
from those original amazing spider-man movies
and toby maguire spider-man movies like the major
gwen stacy moment at the end of the trailer where
he's trying to save mj you can't save everybody
spider-man this is all my fault i can't save
everyone there's a new version of the scene with
doctor strange's spell where they confirm what
actually happened to make things go wrong they do
confirm the meme local man ruins everything doctor
strange was blending together elements to make
everyone forget but something spider-man did while
this was happening caused it to go awry and that's
how the sinister six villains get brought to the
main mcu universe re-watching this footage of when
he's giving spider-man the business doctor strange
sounds so pissed off at him we get a longer
version of the bridge scene with updated special
effects confirmed green goblin and his glider
here with dr octopus so he's fighting multiple
sinister six villains in a lot of his different
fights across the movie the glider the costume is
meant to be the exact same from the first tobey
maguire spider-man movie the reason why it just
looks a little bit different is because modern
special effects are just so much better but it
is meant to be the same suit and it is meant to be
willem dafoe's green goblin from the moment before
he died like they kind of explained later in the
trailer they die because of fights that they have
with spider-man the difference though is that
doctor strange makes it sound like they have
people coming from every single universe
but we only see sinister six villains from
like two different universes here in three if you
count venom because of the venom lithiby carnage
post-credit scene so i'll address this in a second
when we get to that part of the trailer but later
in all those statue of liberty scenes where it's
holding the giant captain america shield and you
see the sky just tearing all around them it sounds
like that's sort of a lead-in to doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness like reality starts to
crumble around them and it gets really really bad
we get our first electro scene you see what
spider-man's costume looks like when he turns
it inside out they've kind of confirmed this
with some of the merchandise too the black suit
is really just the red advanced suit the steve
ditko red and black suit from spider-man far from
home just turned inside out we get a much longer
version of the doctor octopus fight on the george
washington bridge with him just throwing all this
stuff at him with his octopus arms then the way
this scene plays out with him being confused about
tom hall and spider-man it sounds like he believes
when he first sees spider-man in the iron spider
costume he thinks that it's toby maguire's version
of peter parker like oh hello peter parker
and then once he's able to get his octopus
arms around him and immobilize him it seems like
what's happening here is that he uses his octopus
arms to steal his iron spider nanites like there's
some functionality inside the arms because they're
sentient that allows them to hack his iron
spider suit and take the nanites and that's
why you see his octopus arms changing to the iron
man colors like the traditional red gold colors
there's a really big amazing spider-man comic book
easter egg on this license plate they did that
during spider-man far from home and even during
spider-man homecoming all the license plates wound
up being big easter eggs for spider-man comics
then they have their whole scooby-doo thing
going on in the trailer doctor strange literally
calls them the scooby gang when he tells them to
clean up the mess that spider-man created somehow
he's able to trap doctor octopus in one of doctor
strange's prisons in this underground lair and
it sounds like this happens before he captures
the other sinister six villains and doctor octopus
sort of tells him about what's going on with these
multiverse versions of the characters like they
laugh about his name like your name is dr octopus
really which reminds you of j jonah jameson giving
the character his name during spider-man 2. guy
named otto octavius winds up with eight limbs what
are the odds what are we gonna call this guy uh
uh doctor octopus that's crap uh science squid
crap doctor strange that's pretty good but it's
taken he was the person who started calling him
doctor octopus within that universe but when he
says you're going to capture ghosts he's basically
talking about how they all died during fights with
other versions of spider-man and that sort of
sets off the whole spider-man vs doctor strange
plot in the movie where spider-man is trying to
find a way to fix things without having to kill
these other sinister six villains by sending them
back because he'd basically be sending them back
to their deaths there's even a scene with jamie
foxx's electro saying you're not taking this
away from me like he knows that he'll die if he
goes back there has to be another way there isn't
there a danger to our universe you're
not going to take this away from me
obviously all the statue of liberty scenes
implied that this is going to be probably
from the big climax of the movie like one of the
big final fights but i believe the reason why it
has captain america shield is because they're
celebrating falcon becoming captain america
it's also a funny call back to captain america
civil war where spider-man actually used or stole
captain america's shield it's just that this time
it's a massive massive version of the shield we
get some clues about how he captures some of these
sinister six films doctor strange's spells and how
they work with his costume so it sounds like he
modifies some of his gauntlets here to allow him
to wield magic and the spell is basically meant
to trap them in those special prisons like when
he uses it it will send them to doctor strange's
prisons we also get some clues about the different
look for electro's character like he looks kind of
blue in the background here but he's got yellowish
lightning so it probably has something to do
with him just absorbing different kinds of energy
and that being the reason why later in the
movie he gives off different colored lightning
just making him a little bit more comic book
accurate we get a longer version of this daily
bugle scene revealing that j jonah jameson is
actually on the ground so it's not just a video of
him in the movie he's literally in the movie this
time then i love this whole spider-man vs doctor
strange sequence so this is sort of like a reverse
version of the avengers infinity war portal scene
where you have spider-man jumping in and out
of his portals fighting thanos except this time
it's doctor strange using his portals to try and
trap spider-man and keep him from getting away
he also uses the same spell against spider-man
that he used against thanos to pull him in to
like reel him in kind of like a fish and he pulls
the same trick on spider-man that the ancient one
used on him and used on the hulk during avengers
end game they've been teasing that they're gonna
have one of the biggest action scenes in the
history of marvel movies so far and it sounds
like it's basically spider-man maybe toby maguire
maybe andrew garfield spider-man gave him some
assistance during this but they don't show up
during the trailer but it's basically spider-man
versus all five of the sinister six characters
at the same time and also now confirming that it
is rhys ethon's version of the lizard in the suit
that he's wearing when he's fighting them in the
statue of liberty fight is called the integrated
suit it's sort of like an upgraded version of the
iron spider suit then they have their big quen
stacy scene with spider-man trying to save mj
gwen stacy's style like it's a big callback
to andrew garfield's amazing spider-man 2
where he was not able to save gwen stacy which
is why tom hall and spider-man on the trailer
saying i can't save everyone making you think they
might kill mj during the movie but i don't think
it'll wind up going down the same way i think
they'll find a way to save her with a big twist
early theory if andrew garfield's amazing
spider-man were going to help him in some way it
would probably be to help him save mj like picture
all these big fight scenes around the statue of
liberty in this giant giant version of captain
america's shield with another version or two maybe
of spider-man from the multiverse like i said that
could be andrew garfield's amazing spider-man here
who's supposed to be punching the lizard like when
it seems like he's getting punched by absolutely
nothing just a really misleading trailer edit
to make us believe that he's not in the movie
in the tag scene they end on when doctor strange
says they're coming through and i can't stop them
he's probably just talking about way way worse
things coming through from the multiverse and i
think that would be a sort of lead-in for doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness where things get
even crazier with scarlet witch but if you
spotted any huge easter eggs in the trailer
i didn't talk about in the video just write
them below in the comments and i'll do a longer
video for this with more easter eggs tomorrow
you can click here for that video i'll update
the link as soon as i post that and click
here for my marvel moon knight trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!